Ronnie where'd you grow up pretty from
Arlen Texas Dallas vintage for jealously
yeah and tell me what your childhood
you've both your parents growing up no
just my mom and expect Mackey's and the
family and just my mom you know and um
she was at the heart so you know she
wasn't a station so much you know so
what was going on and you know in the
house
well that was that he was away I don't
know exactly where he was some of some
other town did you ever meet that I met
him but it was like you know I never
that got to spend time with him you know
you know was how do you describe your
childhood with hobble man you know my my
big brother I was seven my big brother
should i retina and night and then my
brother next day under him he should pee
in the bed right and put me in the
period I should be a bookings but like I
peed I mean he should put it up pushed
me over into the Pete he's getting the
dry part you know where I was and also I
had it like a babysitter you know she
was like make me do things sexual things
you know it was you know it was just
what it wasn't right you know so you're
getting it from your brother as well as
the babysitter yeah how long just go on
like five years
you know from seven as well
so how were your teenage years are you
in high school I couldn't focus you well
you know on the school that grade you
know because I was like this my mom just
wonder you know about what happened to
the end I just couldn't focus on so much
now you know so I was in the lack of
special very fast you know like one hour
day after they had a class but the
special various I've been slowly but one
hour a day you know and it just wasn't
it wasn't like he should have been to me
you know it was ugly and then after
after high school
where'd you go from there well at the
hospital I just well see what happened
when I was 16 right I was 15 my sister
became my garden here because my mom was
never there my older sister so she sent
me to San Diego California when I was
fixing you though cuz I had I had a
brother right that stayed there you know
yes we had a one-bedroom apartment two
kids and a wife so when I got there you
know that way you know it wasn't that it
wasn't comfortable man so I could
actually switch you know I just search
for the solution tried to back survive
and then they act I had to go to school
so he put me in school I went for the
Lincoln High School so you were living
on the streets during high school no I
like I would live without different
people you know that got no different
friends on that I would live with him
and we know went to school very high
school yeah so you were at home with
your family no my family's my pal like I
sent to San Diego oh I said when I was
fixing okay from San Diego I came here
in 2004 I was 15 years old my sister
sent me to San Diego you know at fifteen
you know it was like what I would like
to do you know I mean
so I got it I got Senegal my brother he
after I left his place he had one big
room like I said it's you cheating and
the wife well what you know well was i
sleeping you know name so I laughing
just went to downtown San Diego and so I
survived I've met people and then he
chanted found me he said you got to go
to school
we're out of puts in school okay you
know so I went to school I'm there you
know but I wasn't like a little hotel
you know I'm trying new friends I stayed
with them you know but you know that
went to school with me staying with him
then mom was out like whether you know
because I you know I was quiet I didn't
bother people you know I wasn't I wasn't
trouble for nobody
you know I've gone through so much in my
head that happened to me in fact I can't
focus on too much in that yes so I don't
know I wasn't a problem for people so
your adult life has been spent doing
what mostly mostly man just writing this
piece man didn't pass the pegs you know
yeah tonight today you're living on Skid
Row
yeah you're in a tent well no I I see by
the bank by bank of America and I have a
friend ever after she actually strumming
my little whatever I have a in innocence
and then in the morning I come yeah but
I knew when my blankie put it back you
know like that she's just a because I
have yeah yeah I have a blanket on the
street yeah I have a blanket and I sleep
in the back of the bank of america you
know if I don't trust people maybe these
well-meaning shaky kind of sleeping yes
there's been a chair whatever you know
makes me a bit I don't stress people I
can't I mean you think because of that
is what happened to you in your so
another gotta be there cuz I just people
brought me to know the sleepover they
pay for whatever that I can say no I'm
all right you know and then one time I
got on my feet come take a shower
o-72 name he's good
hopefully I figure an official and I
wasn't and I said come only one come
take a shower go but I say I think I had
dividend even knowing and he's got the
retinue man he was you had that one
plastic leg he I guess he was on the
military whatever yeah but he had
associated ago I've had to cover I'm in
that struggling with inside and I mean
I'm like she that's messed up I don't
that's why I don't trust people they'd
be nicely I guess they're usually in a
situation where I mean they figure they
can take control you know have you ever
been married or Egypt it's no never had
to desire for pretty straight again here
I'm saying you know sometimes I mean I'm
not gonna lie from what happened to me
you know sometime I may be with a man
but I prefer women you know that's not
pressing there's a woman you know what
do you do for money no I just ask people
on a spotlight said you know actually
for yeah he's on the freeway you know
using drugs at all
I smoke I smoke weed and I drink a
little beer I don't like hard liquor you
know but you know my life is screw back
messed up there because like drugs I
tried it I can't deal with it the
people's had to take advantage of you to
own that when you get to use that you
know they're you that as a device to you
but they welcome you able to smoke
mother with everybody and take a beer
you know I you know it's five I tried
that they know it don't work that people
would say Comanches
I'm sure you credit that but what
happened to you when you were young I
think when I was in fear that I just
grew my life up you know you screwed my
life up you ever talk with your brother
ever since then man he act like it never
happened that was years ago I've seen it
in San Diego he act like it never
happened
I never talked about it you know I mean
I want stuff in there well why you
should do that to me
so what'd you tell them I said oh you
know what's going on
I was never man he said you better shut
up me Ben I never say that about that
you know he liked the records you know
like excuse you ever say something
you know and I was terrified that he
would you know me I got credit that sure
all that's or what happened to me you
know it's inspect you just don't do that
for people I cheat come on man you know
I would never do that to nobody
it's horrible ya know so where do you
see your life going from here hold it
hold it up [ __ ] mean I did you know
yeah look I got hit by two cars man 2018
in 2013 that's from LA
that's one [ __ ] you know no probably
never walk I would never walk be normal
again walking almost but I once had to
do something man I don't know what it is
whatever whatever God put me to do sit
fix that for me and I'm well I'm aside
of that I'll ask her back work with kids
and stuff you know gotta give me a job
like this challenge is about you loving
beer beer what you call it like a
motivational speaker
something you know go they'll be able to
build you sinners and chocolate see for
kids you know and let them know I you
know be kind of something happen to you
that you love not comfortable whiskey
toute tell somebody about it don't let
it happen to me cuz I didn't do that I
let it happen to me nothing
do you ever get a chance to talk about
it with anyone like you know he's
good questions and then your customers
finish the real story should help reduce
he said he was a good person and I know
I know you know he's a good that guy
treated me good you know you got you got
food and you know whatever ya know he
makes sure people don't mess with me and
fast enough so I trust him
especially you know he spelled me back
to you so I think comfortable with you
opening up to you but your story I think
there must be others out there a man I
know man I'm not the father not the only
fear that went through that back there
nobody else experienced something
similar you have a day they'll probably
fear this here speak out about it you
know that's probably very helpful to
hear your story yeah I hope so I hope
you could help somebody else in stop if
something happen in your life you're
scrappy you know maybe that tell
somebody and something to be done about
it you know I mean or a parent might be
a little more a pair of Mike well what's
going on yeah Pam I feel old any
thoughts I would say oh my god no wonder
my faul acting like this I think about
checking into them and [ __ ] making sure
no stops no make sure they okay if
anybody bothering them or taking
advantage of them sexually or whatever
so I hope if you help somebody else you
know I will I really prayed any will you
know you know I'm it's the first time I
ever do something like this but hey
maybe I should have been do you have
somebody that's that way yeah
do you do you feel that you're an angry
person you don't seem angry I'm not you
know because I realized that I was
refuted I've taken advantage of you know
I trusted the people I shouldn't accept
it you know I just you know I I can't be
angry if something that has to live with
it happened okay it happened so
I live with it so why should I be angry
take it out on some others here to do
something like that nothing that's not
gonna make things difference for what
happened to me I love people I just
don't trust everybody
I don't trust going to people a partner
and so nothing except like that I just
do not like that's conclusive
you know I rather be outside well you
know maybe they can't do nothing the
outside somebody's field you know I even
had my friend that the guy that was
killing homeless people [ __ ] my friend
the guy that caught that boy watching
homes people taking the backpack but my
friends got killed by him you know I've
seen my friend two days before it
happened you know so I'm like man I'm
glad they caught that guy you know I
really like that it's some bad people in
this world it's a good algorithm no you
but my spirit I'm comfortable I'm I'm
comfortable you know and I'm glad I'm
doing this because like I hope you could
have some life yeah no I got you to talk
about it too and it helps me to freak
it takes a load off me it shakes me how
a bigger load off me
you know the David sit here and talk
about this next Ronnie thank you so much
for coming in anytime and sure you're
starting oh I'm glad I'm grateful for
you thank you thank you
peace
you